This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.|||这是一个 I-Heart 播客。品质保证。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人 Kear Games 主持的《Learn the Hardway》。这个空间聚焦黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都觉得不太安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行这些对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，去收听
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more|||在 iHeartRadio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 the hard way。2%。这就是当旁边有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中。我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，心理韧性、健身以及培养抗挫力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更
fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.|||充实、更健康的。收听《2%》。即 iHeartRadio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方的 TWO%。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个惯犯骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到他应得的下场。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.|||收听《The Girlfriends: Trust me, babe》，在 iHeartRadio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我和说是个大日子。84年对我也很重要。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每期节目，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Today's episode is going to be a little bit different. We are not talking about you know, something that every 20-something is going to do, which I typically like to center my
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Today's episode is going to be a little bit different. We are not talking about you know, something that every 20-something is going to do, which I typically like to center my|||和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是个疯狂的年份。那真是个疯狂的年份。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。在 iHeartRadio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 look back at it。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听友，老听友，无论你们身在世界的哪个角落。很高兴大家能回来收听另一期节目，当然，我们要剖析的是二十多岁的心理学。今天的节目会有点不同。我们不打算讨论，你知道的，每个二十多岁的人都会做的事，这通常是我喜欢围绕其展开的
episodes on. We're not even talking about psychology all that much, but of course, it is still going to be an element of that. What we are talking about is my new book, mainly the process by which I was able to write it. My book took me around four to six months to write, to write the first draft, first draft I was really, really happy with. And then from there, there was. There was so many extra hidden steps that I think that no one really talks about when they say they want to write a book or when they're talking about authorship. I think we have this idea in our heads of like, okay, I'll write a book, I'll put everything into it. It will take me a couple months and then it will come out. And as soon as I'm done writing it, you know, the next shipment of books that are coming in,
episodes on. We're not even talking about psychology all that much, but of course, it is still going to be an element of that. What we are talking about is my new book, mainly the process by which I was able to write it. My book took me around four to six months to write, to write the first draft, first draft I was really, really happy with. And then from there, there was. There was so many extra hidden steps that I think that no one really talks about when they say they want to write a book or when they're talking about authorship. I think we have this idea in our heads of like, okay, I'll write a book, I'll put everything into it. It will take me a couple months and then it will come out. And as soon as I'm done writing it, you know, the next shipment of books that are coming in,|||节目的主题。我们甚至不会过多地谈论心理学，但当然，这仍然会是其中的一部分。我们要谈论的是我的新书，主要是我是如何写出它的过程。我的书大概花了我四到六个月的时间来写，写初稿，我对第一版初稿感到非常非常满意。然后从那之后，还有。还有许多额外的隐藏步骤，我觉得当人们说他们想写书或者谈论写作时，没有人真正谈论过这些。我想我们脑海中都有这样一种想法，比如，好吧，我要写本书，我会把一切都倾注进去。花几个月时间，然后它就会出版。而且只要我一写完，你知道的，下一批运进来的书，
that's going to have my name on it. It's such a secretive process almost. And I know that so many people have on their bucket list on one of their huge life goals is to write a novel, is to write a book. And having done it, having slugged through it, suffered through it, but also really enjoyed the process at times, I thought that this would be something interesting to talk about and to also be able to answer the questions that so many of you have been asking me in the lead-up to person in progress's release. This is such a great opportunity when this is fresh. In my mind to really talk about the secret ins and outs of book writing. So I know this episode, it might not necessarily appeal to everyone who is a long-time listener of the psychology of
that's going to have my name on it. It's such a secretive process almost. And I know that so many people have on their bucket list on one of their huge life goals is to write a novel, is to write a book. And having done it, having slugged through it, suffered through it, but also really enjoyed the process at times, I thought that this would be something interesting to talk about and to also be able to answer the questions that so many of you have been asking me in the lead-up to person in progress's release. This is such a great opportunity when this is fresh. In my mind to really talk about the secret ins and outs of book writing. So I know this episode, it might not necessarily appeal to everyone who is a long-time listener of the psychology of|||上面就会印着我的名字。这几乎是一个极其神秘的过程。我知道有很多人在他们的愿望清单上，他们人生中最大的目标之一就是写一部小说，写一本书。而当我亲身经历过，熬过来了，痛苦过，但在某些时刻也真的很享受这个过程之后，我觉得这会是一个很有趣的话题，并且能够回答在《成长的草稿》（Person in Progress）发售前期，你们许多人一直在问我的问题趁着记忆犹新，这是一个绝佳的机会。在我的脑海里真正谈谈写书的秘密内幕。所以我知道这期节目，可能不一定会吸引到所有《二十岁心理学》的长期听众，
your 20s, but for those of you who it does, honestly, I find this stuff so fascinating. I listen to so many podcasts when I was writing my book about how to do this. So I thought I'd add my own tips to the story and to the wealth of information out there. If you've ever wanted to write a book, if it's something on your bucket list, if you are currently writing a book, if you just want to understand the artistic process a little bit more, maybe learn something. This episode is for you. I am so excited. We're going to cut the intro nice and short so we can get into the nice, juicy stuff without further ado. Let's talk about how I wrote my book Person in Progress. Okay, so for the last six months, I've been writing all of my thoughts and feelings
your 20s, but for those of you who it does, honestly, I find this stuff so fascinating. I listen to so many podcasts when I was writing my book about how to do this. So I thought I'd add my own tips to the story and to the wealth of information out there. If you've ever wanted to write a book, if it's something on your bucket list, if you are currently writing a book, if you just want to understand the artistic process a little bit more, maybe learn something. This episode is for you. I am so excited. We're going to cut the intro nice and short so we can get into the nice, juicy stuff without further ado. Let's talk about how I wrote my book Person in Progress. Okay, so for the last six months, I've been writing all of my thoughts and feelings|||但对于那些感兴趣的人来说，老实说，我发现这些内容太迷人了。自我写书以来，我听了好多关于如何写书的播客。所以我认为我可以在这个故事以及现有的丰富信息中加入我自己的小贴士。如果你曾经想写一本书，如果这是你愿望清单上的一项，如果你目前正在写一本书，如果你只是想对艺术创作过程有更多的了解，或者想学到点什么。这期节目就是为你准备的。我太激动了。我们要把开场白精简一下，这样我们就可以直接进入精彩、带劲的内容了。废话不多说，我们来聊聊我是如何写出我的新书《成长的草稿》的。好吧，在过去的六个月里，我一直在我的备忘录应用中写下我所有的想法和感受，
about book writing in my notes app. I kind of always knew I wanted to document this, which is great for me now because all of my thoughts, it's all here. It's all ready to be shared. Let me start with explaining why I knew I wanted to write a book because I think that that why is really, really important and often neglected. I want to remind you, it's not that you want to write a book. You should want to write the book. A specific book that you know needs to be written, that you feel you'll call to in your heart to put out there, that you feel like it just needs to be spoken, it needs to be written down. There is no other option going forward that does not involve you creating this thing. Here are some of the questions I would ask myself or that you can ask
about book writing in my notes app. I kind of always knew I wanted to document this, which is great for me now because all of my thoughts, it's all here. It's all ready to be shared. Let me start with explaining why I knew I wanted to write a book because I think that that why is really, really important and often neglected. I want to remind you, it's not that you want to write a book. You should want to write the book. A specific book that you know needs to be written, that you feel you'll call to in your heart to put out there, that you feel like it just needs to be spoken, it needs to be written down. There is no other option going forward that does not involve you creating this thing. Here are some of the questions I would ask myself or that you can ask|||关于写书的心得。我其实一直都知道我想记录下来，这对我现在来说太棒了，因为我所有的想法，全都在这儿了。它们都准备好分享了。让我先解释一下为什么我知道自己想写一本书，因为我觉得那个“为什么”真的非常重要，却常常被忽视。我想提醒你，并不是“你想写一本书”。你应该想要写“那本书”。一本你知道非写不可的特定书，一本你觉得内心深处呼唤你将其创作出来的书，一本你觉得它必须被说出来、必须被写下来的书。往前走，没有其他选择能绕过你亲手创造这个东西。以下是我会问自己的一些问题，或者你可以问自己的问题，
yourself to understand what kind of book is it that you actually want to write. The biggest thing to notice is if you want to write a book, what is the thing that you already could talk about all day? what is the thing that you think about the most? What is the topic, idea, conversation that you bring up with your friends all the time? What is the thing you feel like you can't not write about? What we're really getting to here is trying to find the direction in which you should be placing your efforts and trying almost to uncover the idea that I think we all have. All of us have a brilliant story that only we can tell.
yourself to understand what kind of book is it that you actually want to write. The biggest thing to notice is if you want to write a book, what is the thing that you already could talk about all day? what is the thing that you think about the most? What is the topic, idea, conversation that you bring up with your friends all the time? What is the thing you feel like you can't not write about? What we're really getting to here is trying to find the direction in which you should be placing your efforts and trying almost to uncover the idea that I think we have. All of us have a brilliant story that only we can tell.|||以此来了解你到底想写一本什么样的书。最需要注意的一点是，如果你想写书，有什么事情是你本来就可以聊上一整天的？你最常想的是什么？你经常和朋友提起的主题、想法、谈话是什么？有什么事情是你觉得不写不行的？我们真正要探讨的是，试图找到你应该付出努力的方向，几乎是去发掘那个我认为我们都拥有的灵感。我们每个人都有一个只有我们自己才能讲述的精彩故事。
all of us have some kind of knowledge or lived experience with the topic that hasn't been told before. The thing is, it's about identifying that. Now, another element of this is that there are some books that you might think you can write that you just shouldn't. And it feels strange because maybe you are sitting on a million idea and you're thinking, oh my gosh, I should really write this book or someone should, but you have no motivation to begin. You have no idea what would happen with it. you have no storyline, nothing like that. That is either the start of a really great idea,
all of us have some kind of knowledge or lived experience with the topic that hasn't been told before. The thing, it's about identifying that. Now, another element of this is that there are some books that you might think you can write that you just shouldn't. And it feels strange because maybe you are sitting on a million idea and you're thinking, oh my gosh, I should really write this book or someone should, but you have no motivation to begin. You have no idea what would happen with it. you have no storyline, nothing like that. That is either the start of a really great idea,|||我们所有人对于某个从未被讲述过的主题，都有某种知识或生活经验。关键在于，要识别出这一点。现在，其中的另一个因素是，有些书你可能觉得自己能写，但其实你根本不该写。这感觉很奇怪，因为也许你脑子里正揣着一个价值百万的点子，心想：天哪，我真的应该写这本书，或者别人应该写，但你完全没有开始的动力。你不知道它会朝什么方向发展。你没有故事情节，什么都没有。这要么是一个绝妙点子的开端，
or it's a sign that that idea actually doesn't belong to you. So I heard this brilliant analogy by Elizabeth Gilbert, who we've interviewed on the podcast before, and she explains how ideas, we don't necessarily own them. Before we create something, all we have is an idea. But until we put that idea and make it into something tangible, and we put it into fruition. Anyone is welcome to come and take it.
or it's a sign that that idea actually doesn't belong to you. So I heard this brilliant analogy by Elizabeth Gilbert, who we've interviewed on the podcast before, and she explains how ideas, we don't necessarily own them. Before we create something, all we have is an idea. But until we put that idea and make it into something tangible, and we put it into fruition. Anyone is welcome to come and take it.|||要么就是一个信号，表明这个点子其实根本不属于你。所以我听过伊丽莎白·吉尔伯特（我们曾在播客中采访过她）的一个精彩比喻，她解释了点子这东西，我们并不一定拥有它们。在我们创作任何东西之前，我们拥有的只是一个点子。但直到我们把这个点子变成具体的东西，并让它结出硕果。任何人都欢迎来拿走它。
Anyone is welcome to have dibs to it. Essentially what she explains is that there are all these ideas that are kind of existing around us and within the walls. There are all these stories that the universe once told. And they are going to find the person, the universe, the spirits, whatever it is, the Roman gods, the Greek gods, God in general, this force is going to find the person he was going to be able to execute that idea most succinctly and quickly.
Anyone is welcome to have dibs to it. Essentially what she explains is that there are all these ideas that are kind of existing around us and within the walls. There are all these stories that the universe once told. And they are going to find the person, the universe, the spirits, whatever it is, the Roman gods, the Greek gods, God in general, this force is going to find the person he was going to be able to execute that idea most succinctly and quickly.|||任何人都可以先下手为强。她本质上解释的是，有各种各样的点子存在于我们周围和墙壁之内。有宇宙曾经讲述过的各种故事。它们会找到那个人，宇宙、精灵，无论是什么，罗马神、希腊神、一般意义上的上帝，这股力量会找到那个最能简洁、快速地将这个点子付诸实践的人。
So if you have an idea for a book, but you really are actually just not that committed to it, it's okay to let that idea go and leave space for a better one or a more fresh, personal, interesting idea to you because perhaps that idea doesn't really belong to you. The reason I've put so much time into explaining this is because that happened to me. the initial book that I wanted to write, I now realize was not my book. I initially wanted to write. I had two ideas. I initially wanted to essentially keep a journal for two years and then publish
So if you have an idea for a book, but you really are actually just not that committed to it, it's okay to let that idea go and leave space for a better one or a more fresh, personal, interesting idea to you because perhaps that idea doesn't really belong to you. The reason I've put so much time into explaining this is because that happened to me. the initial book that I wanted to write, I now realize was not my book. I initially wanted to write. I had two ideas. I initially wanted to essentially keep a journal for two years and then publish|||所以，如果你有一个写书的想法，但你其实并没有那么投入，没关系，大可以放手这个想法，为另一个更好、更清新、对你而言更有趣、更私人的想法留出空间，因为也许那个想法本来就不属于你。我花这么多时间来解释这一点，是因为这种事发生在我身上过。我最初想写的那本书，现在我意识到那根本不是我的书。我最初想写的是。我有两个想法。我最初的想法基本上是写两年的日记，然后出版
certain journal entries as like an anthology or a collection of like the 20 something diaries, which if you follow me on Instagram, you'll know as something that I do over there. But I wanted to basically give people almost. the ability to buy my diary with like handwritten entries in it on like a mass scale. A couple problems with that. I still think it's a good idea and if someone else wants to do it, like it's not my idea anymore. Like I'm not going to make that idea so someone else is welcome to do it. I think the issue with that is that it is quite vulnerable and it what it made me realize is that I would end up writing in my journal, in my diary, as if there was
certain journal entries as like an anthology or a collection of like the 20 something diaries, which if you follow me on Instagram, you'll know as something that I do over there. But I wanted to basically give people almost. the ability to buy my diary with like handwritten entries in it on like a mass scale. A couple problems with that. I still think it's a good idea and if someone else wants to do it, like it's not my idea anymore. Like I'm not going to make that idea so someone else is welcome to do it. I think the issue with that is that it is quite vulnerable and it what it made me realize is that I would end up writing in my journal, in my diary, as if there was|||某些日记条目，就像一个选集或二十多岁日记的合集，如果你在 Instagram 上关注了我，你就会知道这是我在那边做的事情。但我基本上是想让人们几乎能够大规模地买到带有手写字迹的我的日记。这其中有几个问题。我仍然觉得这是个好主意，如果别人想做，那这就不是我的点子了。就像我不会去实现那个点子一样，所以其他人完全可以去做。我认为其中的问题在于，这非常脆弱，而且它让我意识到，我最终在日记本里写东西时，会表现得好像
already an audience there, as if someone was already perceiving everything that I'd written. Because I was already committed to the practice, I already journal basically every single day. But at the point that I decided that those journals were going to be published, obviously, that was going to completely disrupt the artistic and also the emotional and personal process of that practice. So that was the first idea and I realized, like, that's not going to work. The second idea was that I wanted to write this book called the overachievers guide to doing less. And I wanted to talk about how through mistakes and errors and faults and flaws and this whole process, I have kind of learnt to put less pressure on myself. And I know that there are so
already an audience there, as if someone was already perceiving everything that I'd written. Because I was already committed to the practice, I already journal basically every single day. But at the point that I decided that those journals were going to be published, obviously, that was going to completely disrupt the artistic and also the emotional and personal process of that practice. So that was the first idea and I realized, like, that's not going to work. The second idea was that I wanted to write this book called the overachievers guide to doing less. And I wanted to talk about how through mistakes and errors and faults and flaws and this whole process, I have kind of learnt to put less pressure on myself. And I know that there are so|||已经有一个受众在那里了，好像已经有人在感知我写下的所有东西一样。因为我已经习惯了这种做法，我基本上每天都写日记。但当我决定要将这些日记出版的那一刻起，显然，这将会彻底打破这种做法的艺术性，以及其中的情感和个人过程。所以这是第一个想法，我意识到，这行不通。第二个想法是，我想写一本名为《完美主义者的减负指南》（The Overachiever's Guide to Doing Less）的书。我想谈谈我是如何通过错误、失误、缺点、瑕疵以及整个过程，逐渐学会减少对自己的压力的。我知道有非常多的人
many individuals out there who are very type A and who were raised as gifted overachievers who to this day struggle with this idea that their output is their entire worth. And I really wanted to write a self-help book, I guess, debunking that idea and providing like tangible practical ways to re-centre your life on things that you actually enjoy and that bring you joy rather than on what seems impressive for other people, how hard you can work, how much you can push yourself. So those were two ideas that I had before I decided to write person in progress. And I am fully okay with the fact that, yes, those may have been great ideas, but that was not the book that I was being called to write. The book that I was being called to write was this book was person in progress. This is how I
many individuals out there who are very type A and who were raised as gifted overachievers who to this day struggle with this idea that their output is their entire worth. And I really wanted to write a self-help book, I guess, debunking that idea and providing like tangible practical ways to re-centre your life on things that you actually enjoy and that bring you joy rather than on what seems impressive for other people, how hard you can work, how much you can push yourself. So those were two ideas that I had before I decided to write person in progress. And I am fully okay with the fact that, yes, those may have been great ideas, but that was not the book that I was being called to write. The book that I was being called to write was this book was person in progress. This is how I|||都是A型人格，从小作为天赋异禀的优等生被抚养长大，直到今天仍在与这样一种观点作斗争：他们的产出就是他们的全部价值。我真的很想写一本自助书，我想，去打破这种观念，并提供切实可行的实用方法，把你的生活重新中心化，聚焦在你真正喜欢、能给你带来快乐的事情上，而不是去关注在别人眼里显得多么厉害、你能工作多努力、你能把自己逼得多紧。所以在决定写《成长的草稿》之前，我有过这两个想法。我完全接受这样一个事实：是的，这些可能都是很棒的点子，但那并不是我被召唤去写的书。我被召唤去写的书就是这本书——《成长的草稿》。我是这样
figured that out. I figured it out because it was what I was already obsessed with and I was actually already writing about. The podcast, the psychology of your 20s, like those episodes could have made a novel. And something that not many people know is that actually most of these episodes are scripted. And that requires me to write, you know, somewhere, anywhere between 4,000 to 7,000 words for every single script. And I was doing that, like, happily. I was so involved in that process of writing my scripts to a week, sometimes 10,000, 12,000, 13,000 words that I kind of took a step back. I was like, like, oh, I'm already writing this book. I'm writing this book just in a different form. So what's the challenge going to be? What's the big difference? Like, this is the book that I'm being called
figured that out. I figured it out because it was what I was already obsessed with and I was actually already writing about. The podcast, the psychology of your 20s, like those episodes could have made a novel. And something that not many people know is that actually most of these episodes are scripted. And that requires me to write, you know, somewhere, anywhere between 4,000 to 7,000 words for every single script. And I was doing that, like, happily. I was so involved in that process of writing my scripts to a week, sometimes 10,000, 12,000, 13,000 words that I kind of took a step back. I was like, like, oh, I'm already writing this book. I'm writing this book just in a different form. So what's the challenge going to be? What's the big difference? Like, this is the book that I'm being called|||想通这一点的。我想通了，因为这就是我本来就痴迷、并且实际上已经在写的东西。《二十岁心理学》这个播客，那些节目内容完全可以凑成一部小说。很多人不知道的一点是，其实这些节目大多是有剧本的。这就要求我，你知道的，为每个剧本写大约 4,000 到 7,000 字不等的内容。而且我写得很开心。我深深地投入到了每周写剧本的过程中，有时一周能写 10,000、12,000、13,000 字，以至于我退后一步想了想。我想，噢，我其实已经在写这本书了。我只是在以另一种形式写这本书。那挑战会是什么呢？最大的区别在哪里？这就是我被召唤去写的书啊。
to write. The other thing was that I could not stop taking notes of everything around me that I was almost already committed to putting in the book. Let me explain that. So I remember specifically there's a story in the book of one of my friends, and she previously had like the most terrible workplace, and she had a terrible boss, and it was just an awful experience. And I remember hearing that story and talking it through with her and getting really, really involved. And then a part of me was like, wow, like, that would be a great part of this book. Like, someone could even write a whole book around this.
to write. The other thing was that I could not stop taking notes of everything around me that I was almost already committed to putting in the book. Let me explain that. So I remember specifically there's a story in the book of one of my friends, and she previously had like the most terrible workplace, and she had a terrible boss, and it was just an awful experience. And I remember hearing that story and talking it through with her and getting really, really involved. And then a part of me was like, wow, like, that would be a great part of this book. Like, someone could even write a whole book around this.|||另一件事是，我无法停止记录周围发生的一切，我几乎已经下定决心要把它们写进书里。让我解释一下。我清楚地记得，书中有一个关于我朋友的故事，她以前呆过最糟糕的工作场所，有一个糟糕的上司，那真是一段糟糕的经历。我记得听到这个故事，和她一起讨论，并且非常非常投入地参与其中。然后我心里的一部分就在想：哇，这会是这本书里很棒的一部分。甚至有人可以围绕这个写一整本书呢。
And I wrote down her story, obviously, with her. permission and there were so many other instances like that like friends breakups things i was learning in my own life things i was noticing in the news it felt like the structure was being built by those very ideas and i just had to kind of fill in the blanks and be committed to making it coherent so this is my first big piece of advice if you want to write a book the idea should almost feel natural to you It should feel like already in your mind, already in what you are noticing, in the notes that you are jotting down, you're already committed to writing this book. Like you are already doing research.
And I wrote down her story, obviously, with her. permission and there were so many other instances like that like friends breakups things i was learning in my own life things i was noticing in the news it felt like the structure was being built by those very ideas and i just had to kind of fill in the blanks and be committed to making it coherent so this is my first big piece of advice if you want to write a book the idea should almost feel natural to you It should feel like already in your mind, already in what you are noticing, in the notes that you are jotting down, you're already committed to writing this book. Like you are already doing research.|||我写下了她的故事，当然，是在征得她同意的前提下。还有很多其他类似的情况，比如朋友的分手，我在自己生活中学到的东西，我在新闻中注意到的事情，感觉这本书的结构正是由这些想法搭建起来的，我只需要把空白填满，并致力于让它连贯起来。所以这是我的第一个重要建议：如果你想写一本书，这个点子对你来说应该感觉很自然。它应该让你觉得，在你的脑海里，在你所关注的事物中，在你随手记下的笔记中，你其实已经不知不觉地投入到这本书的创作中了。就像你已经在做调研了一样。
You are already on the lookout for things that will contribute to this story that you know needs to be told that has not been told yet. The next thing I want to talk about, which no one talks about, is how to write a pitch. So there's kind of two ways that you go about writing a book. Either you write the whole book, you write the whole manuscript and then you start looking for a publisher or you have the idea and before you write it, you pitch it to publishing houses and see if they'll give you an advance and see if they'll find you a slot. So a slot is basically the time in the year when your book is going to be released. So something that no one told me before I started writing a book is that
You are already on the lookout for things that will contribute to this story that you know needs to be told that has not been told yet. The next thing I want to talk about, which no one talks about, is how to write a pitch. So there's kind of two ways that you go about writing a book. Either you write the whole book, you write the whole manuscript and then you start looking for a publisher or you have the idea and before you write it, you pitch it to publishing houses and see if they'll give you an advance and see if they'll find you a slot. So a slot is basically the time in the year when your book is going to be released. So something that no one told me before I started writing a book is that|||你已经在留意那些能为这个故事增添光彩的素材了，你知道这个故事非讲不可，而且它还没有被讲述过。接下来我要谈论的事情，是从来没有人谈论过的——如何写一份图书提案（pitch）。所以写一本书大致有两种途径。要么你把整本书写完，写完整部手稿，然后开始寻找出版社；要么你有了这个想法，在动笔之前，先把提案发给各大出版社，看看他们是否愿意给你预付款，看看他们能不能为你安排一个档期。所以“档期”基本上就是一年中你的书将要出版的时间。在我开始写书之前，没有人告诉我的一件事是，
publishers obviously cannot flood the market with every single book that is proposed to them, pitch to them, but also with every single book that they are even working on. You know, they have to kind of stagnate, what's it called like stagger? They have to kind of stagger their release. And so they are looking out for books that are going to fill certain slots in their roster. most publishing houses, they know what books are going to be publishing two years in advance. They know what books going to be coming out in April 2027. That book is already being written right now.
publishers obviously cannot flood the market with every single book that is proposed to them, pitch to them, but also with every single book that they are even working on. You know, they have to kind of stagnate, what's it called like stagger? They have to kind of stagger their release. And so they are looking out for books that are going to fill certain slots in their roster. most publishing houses, they know what books are going to be publishing two years in advance. They know what books going to be coming out in April 2027. That book is already being written right now.|||出版社显然不可能把所有向他们提议、向他们推荐的书籍一股脑儿全塞满市场，甚至他们正在制作的每一本书也是如此。你知道的，他们必须有所停滞，怎么说来着，错开？他们必须错开图书的出版时间。因此，他们一直在寻找能够填补他们出版计划中特定档期的书籍。大多数出版社在提前两年就知道他们将要出版什么书。他们知道2027年4月会出版什么书。那本书现在就已经在创作中了。
And so even if you haven't written the book yet, they are constantly looking for amazing ideas and stories that could fill those slots. So if you want to go that route, what you need to do is write a pitch. This is exactly what a pitch is going to involve. it's going to involve a small section about you, about your experience, about your background, about anything that you think is relevant to why you are writing the story. Perhaps if you are writing a scientific or a health-based book or a self-improvement book or a psychology book, you know, you want to say I have a bit of credibility.
And so even if you haven't written the book yet, they are constantly looking for amazing ideas and stories that could fill those slots. So if you want to go that route, what you need to do is write a pitch. This is exactly what a pitch is going to involve. it's going to involve a small section about you, about your experience, about your background, about anything that you think is relevant to why you are writing the story. Perhaps if you are writing a scientific or a health-based book or a self-improvement book or a psychology book, you know, you want to say I have a bit of credibility.|||所以，即使你还没动笔写书，他们也在不断寻找能够填补这些档期的精彩创意和故事。因此，如果你想走这条路，你需要做的是写一份提案。这就是一份提案将要包含的内容。它将包含关于你的一小部分介绍，关于你的经历，关于你的背景，关于任何你认为与你为什么要写这个故事相关的因素。也许如果你在写一本科学或健康类的书，或者自助书，或者心理学书，你知道的，你会想要表明自己具备一定的可信度。
So I have a degree. I have worked in this space, yada, yada, yada. Maybe if you're writing a fiction book, you want to say, well, this is where I've had pieces published before, that kind of stuff. A little bit of it about me section. Then you want a section that is about the book. Who is the audience going to be? What is the plot line going to be? Who are the characters? What's the story going to be based around? What are the major themes going to be? Why do you think people will read this book? Maybe noticing certain trends. Like if you're writing a romance book thing, well, look, there's the romance industry. It's absolutely thriving.
So I have a degree. I have worked in this space, yada, yada, yada. Maybe if you're writing a fiction book, you want to say, well, this is where I've had pieces published before, that kind of stuff. A little bit of it about me section. Then you want a section that is about the book. Who is the audience going to be? What is the plot line going to be? Who are the characters? What's the story going to be based around? What are the major themes going to be? Why do you think people will read this book? Maybe noticing certain trends. Like if you're writing a romance book thing, well, look, there's the romance industry. It's absolutely thriving.|||比如我有学位。我曾在这一领域工作过，等等等等。也许如果你在写一本小说，你会想说，嗯，这是我以前发表过作品的地方，诸如此类。一部分是“关于我”的内容。接下来你需要一部分关于这本书的内容。目标受众会是谁？故事情节会是怎样的？角色都有谁？故事将围绕什么展开？主要主题会是什么？你为什么认为人们会读这本书？也许要注意到某些趋势。就像如果你在写一本浪漫小说，嗯，你看，言情小说产业正蓬勃发展。
this is where I see my book fitting in here, basically selling your book and saying, you're going to make money off of this, hopefully. Here's why. Here is exactly why and exactly who is going to buy it. Then typically you're going to want to give kind of a section outline, a story outline. For me, obviously I wrote a nonfiction book,
this is where I see my book fitting in here, basically selling your book and saying, you're going to make money off of this, hopefully. Here's why. Here is exactly why and exactly who is going to buy it. Then typically you're going to want to give kind of a section outline, a story outline. For me, obviously I wrote a nonfiction book,|||这就是我看到我的书适合切入的地方，基本上就是兜售你的书，并说：希望你们能靠这个赚钱。原因如下。这就是为什么以及究竟谁会买单。接下来，通常你需要提供一个章节大纲、故事大纲。对我来说，很显然我写的是一本非虚构类书籍，
so I wrote a chapter outline. That will change, but it's basically just like, I've thought about this enough to have something that I can give you to show that I'm prepared to put effort into this and I'm prepared to watch this evolve. So I did like a, I basically just gave them my table of contents, what I expected my table of contents to be. And then I wrote two sample chapters, two sample chapters that I basically was like, I believe these will end up in the final manuscript. And they did end up in the final
so I wrote a chapter outline. That will change, but it's basically just like, I've thought about this enough to have something that I can give you to show that I'm prepared to put effort into this and I'm prepared to watch this evolve. So I did like a, I basically just gave them my table of contents, what I expected my table of contents to be. And then I wrote two sample chapters, two sample chapters that I basically was like, I believe these will end up in the final manuscript. And they did end up in the final|||所以我写了一个章节大纲。这会有所改变，但基本上就像是：我对这事已经思考得足够深入，能拿出一份东西交给你，向你证明我准备为之付出努力，我也准备好看着它不断演变。所以我做了一个，我基本上只是把我的目录给了他们，也就是我预期中的目录。然后我写了两个样章，这两个样章我当时的想法是：我相信它们最终会出现在最终的手稿中。它们确实最终留在了最终的
manuscript, obviously deeply changed and edited, but the overall theme of them was the same. And that's an important component of this because, again, they want to know your tone. They also want to know that you're a good writer. They want to know that, yeah, you're going to be capable of creating something that they actually think is worthy of reading, worthy in their minds. Personally, I think anything that you've written is worthy of reading and rereading and changing, even if no one else is buying it. Like, it's still a beautiful process just to write.
manuscript, obviously deeply changed and edited, but the overall theme of them was the same. And that's an important component of this because, again, they want to know your tone. They also want to know that you're a good writer. They want to know that, yeah, you're going to be capable of creating something that they actually think is worthy of reading, worthy in their minds. Personally, I think anything that you've written is worthy of reading and rereading and changing, even if no one else is buying it. Like, it's still a beautiful process just to write.|||手稿中，当然经过了大量的修改和编辑，但它们的整体主题是一样的。这是其中一个很重要的组成部分，因为同样地，他们想了解你的语气。他们还想知道你是个优秀的作家。他们想知道，是的，你有能力创作出他们认为值得阅读的东西，在他们看来有价值的东西。就我个人而言，我认为你写下的任何东西都值得去阅读、重读和修改，哪怕没有人买它。就像，仅仅是去写作，这本身就是一个美丽的创作过程。
something and create something even if no one ends up buying it. But what they're looking for is sometimes a specific way of writing or a specific, yeah, a specific tone, a specific process that they have kind of seen work for them in the past. I don't really know if I can give you any further detail about that because I think I just went into it being like, this is what I would want to read. This is how, this is my writing style. So I'm just going to write these chapters the way that I would do it if no one was watching. And luckily for me, they really, really liked them. If of course, perhaps you're writing a fiction book, you might, like for me, it was very easy to do two chapters because they were, I think, 15 pages each, so 30 pages in total of my book. And, like, all the chapters
something and create something even if no one ends up buying it. But what they're looking for is sometimes a specific way of writing or a specific, yeah, a specific tone, a specific process that they have kind of seen work for them in the past. I don't really know if I can give you any further detail about that because I think I just went into it being like, this is what I would want to read. This is how, this is my writing style. So I'm just going to write these chapters the way that I would do it if no one was watching. And luckily for me, they really, really liked them. If of course, perhaps you're writing a fiction book, you might, like for me, it was very easy to do two chapters because they were, I think, 15 pages each, so 30 pages in total of my book. And, like, all the chapters|||写点东西、创作点东西，哪怕最终没人买。但他们寻找的有时是一种特定的写作方式，或者特定的，对，一种特定的语调，一种他们过去发现对他们管用的特定流程。我真的不知道能否给你提供更多关于这方面的细节，因为我觉得我当时进到这个环节时，心想的就是：这是我想读的内容。这就是，这是我的写作风格。所以我打算就按照如果没有人在看、我自己会怎么做的那种方式来写这些章节。幸运的是，他们非常非常喜欢。当然，如果你可能在写一本小说，你也许，比如对我来说，写两章非常简单，因为它们每章大概是15页，我的书总共30页。而且，所有的章节
are distinct, right? So like if I was to show you the table of contents, if you have the book, like you'll know that each chapter is its own package, kind of. If you're writing a fiction book, it might be a little bit different. You might have to flesh out the storyline a little bit more, perhaps provide the first few chapters, like the first, you know, the first critical part of the book before they say, yes, we want you to write this. That is how to write a pitch. You are are then welcome to find people's emails. Maybe you find an agent. I had an agent, which I was very lucky to have through like previous relationships that I had. Basically, I said to the person who manages my podcast, like, I really want to write a book. And she was like, I'll get you in touch
are distinct, right? So like if I was to show you the table of contents, if you have the book, like you'll know that each chapter is its own package, kind of. If you’re writing a fiction book, it might be a little bit different. You might have to flesh out the storyline a little bit more, perhaps provide the first few chapters, like the first, you know, the first critical part of the book before they say, yes, we want you to write this. That is how to write a pitch. You are are then welcome to find people's emails. Maybe you find an agent. I had an agent, which I was very lucky to have through like previous relationships that I had. Basically, I said to the person who manages my podcast, like, I really want to write a book. And she was like, I'll get you in touch|||都是独立成篇的，对吧？所以，如果我给你看目录，如果你有这本书，你就会知道每一章基本上都是一个独立的整体。如果你在写一本小说，可能会有点不同。你可能需要把故事情节丰满一些，也许需要提供前几章，比如，你知道的，书中最初的那个关键部分，然后他们才会说：“是的，我们想让你写这个。”这就是如何写一份提案。接下来你就可以去找别人的电子邮箱了。也许你会找个经纪人。我有一个经纪人，我很幸运，通过之前的人脉关系找到了她。基本上，我对管理我播客的人说：“我真的很想写本书。”然后她说：“我帮你联系
with a friend. His name was Dan. He works for UTA. And he basically like handled a lot of this for me. So I can't say that I'm an expert in this part. But essentially what I believed he did was send that pitch to a bunch of people in the industry who he knew and then there is kind of um you basically it's called taking it to market and then people bid on your book if you're lucky enough to have multiple people interested sometimes you might just have one person interested and they go yep we love this book we'll buy the rights this is how much we'll offer you maybe they'll only offer you royalties whatever it is the deal that you're getting um or you might have multiple people which is just like so amazing if you do and so incredible. Literally, someone just reading your manuscript is already a huge
with a friend. His name was Dan. He works for UTA. And he basically like handled a lot of this for me. So I can't say that I'm an expert in this part. But essentially what I believed he did was send that pitch to a bunch of people in the industry who he knew and then there is kind of um you basically it's called taking it to market and then people bid on your book if you're lucky enough to have multiple people interested sometimes you might just have one person interested and they go yep we love this book we'll buy the rights this is how much we'll offer you maybe they'll only offer you royalties whatever it is the deal that you're getting um or you might have multiple people which is just like so amazing if you do and so incredible. Literally, someone just reading your manuscript is already a huge|||一个朋友。他叫丹。他在 UTA 工作。”他基本上帮我处理了很多这方面的事情。所以我不能说我是这方面的专家。但我认为他本质上做的是，把那份提案发给了他在业内认识的一群人，然后就会有一种，嗯，基本上这叫拿到市场上竞标，然后人们会对你的书进行出价，如果你足够幸运有多个买家感兴趣的话，有时你可能只有一个感兴趣的人，他们会说：“行，我们很喜欢这本书，我们要买版权，这是我们开出的价格，”也许他们只提供版税，无论你谈成什么交易，嗯，或者你可能会有多个买家，如果有的话那可真是太棒了、太不可思议了。说实话，仅仅是有人愿意读你的手稿就已经是一个巨大的
success. One person wanting to buy your book is an even bigger success. Two people wanting to buy your book is just insane. So that is something that some people encounter where they've taken it to market. There's kind of a bidding war and the people, the publishing houses will say, well, this is what we can offer you if you publish with us. There is also the opportunity to self-publish to say, okay, I'm going to put a grand, two grand, which is a lot of money, but however much you're willing to put into it, to make copies of this book myself and to get them printed at a local printer and then to go into bookstores and say, hey, I'm a local author. Will you stock my book?
success. One person wanting to buy your book is an even bigger success. Two people wanting to buy your book is just insane. So that is something that some people encounter where they've taken it to market. There's kind of a bidding war and the people, the publishing houses will say, well, this is what we can offer you if you publish with us. There is also the opportunity to self-publish to say, okay, I'm going to put a grand, two grand, which is a lot of money, but however much you're willing to put into it, to make copies of this book myself and to get them printed at a local printer and then to go into bookstores and say, hey, I'm a local author. Will you stock my book?|||成功了。一个人想买你的书，那就是更大的成功。两个人想买你的书简直是疯狂。所以有些人在拿到市场上时就会遇到这种情况。会出现某种竞标战，那些人、那些出版社就会说：“嗯，如果你跟我们签约出版，我们能给你这些条件。”同时也有机会选择自费出版，也就是：“好吧，我要拿出的一千、两千美元（这可是一大笔钱，但取决于你愿意投入多少），自己印这本书的副本，在当地的印刷厂印好，然后走进书店说：‘嘿，我是当地的作者。你们愿意进我的书吗？’”
And you know what? There have been some incredible success stories from people doing this. I don't know if anyone knows this. I guess it's a novel. This book, it's called The Diary of an Oxygen. thief. That book, I remember it being huge and it's like a very gripping story. The anonymous author of that book actually, you know, managed to get a full-time retailer and a full-time publisher from initially pitching it to local bookstores who were like, yeah, we'll buy a couple copies and we'll sell them and
And you know what? There have been some incredible success stories from people doing this. I don't know if anyone knows this. I guess it's a novel. This book, it's called The Diary of an Oxygen. thief. That book, I remember it being huge and it's like a very gripping story. The anonymous author of that book actually, you know, managed to get a full-time retailer and a full-time publisher from initially pitching it to local bookstores who were like, yeah, we'll buy a couple copies and we'll sell them and|||你知道吗？通过这种方式取得不可思议成功的案例有很多。我不知道有没有人知道这个。我猜这是一部小说。这本书，书名叫《氧气小偷的日记》（The Diary of an Oxygen Thief）。我记得这本书当时非常火，而且故事情节非常引人入胜。那本书的匿名作者实际上，你知道的，最初只是向当地的书店推销，书店觉得“行，我们买几本卖卖看”，接着
then they couldn't keep them because people were like, wow, this is such a good book and we're recommending it to their friends. So there are so many routes through which you can do. this. That aside, let's now talk about how to actually write a book, how to actually get to that 70,000, 80,000, 90,000 word limit and enjoy the process because I know this is going to sound dramatic. Writing a book is like birthing a child. Quite literally, you spend more time with that book than someone spends with a child in their womb. Like it takes so many months. It is a labor of love, but there are also some tips and tricks and practices that make it a lot easier and that make it something that you actually feel quite fulfilled by. So we are going to take a
then they couldn't keep them because people were like, wow, this is such a good book and we're recommending it to their friends. So there are so many routes through which you can do. this. That aside, let's now talk about how to actually write a book, how to actually get to that 70,000, 80,000, 90,000 word limit and enjoy the process because I know this is going to sound dramatic. Writing a book is like birthing a child. Quite literally, you spend more time with that book than someone spends with a child in their womb. Like it takes so many months. It is a labor of love, but there are also some tips and tricks and practices that make it a lot easier and that make it something that you actually feel quite fulfilled by. So we are going to take a|||他们发现书根本不够卖，因为大家都在说：“哇，这本书太棒了”，并把它推荐给朋友。所以你可以通过非常多的途径来实现这一点。抛开这些不谈，现在我们来聊聊如何真正去写一本书，如何真正达成7万、8万、9万字的字数目标，并且享受这个过程，因为我知道这听起来可能很戏剧化。写书就像生孩子一样。毫不夸张地说，你陪伴那本书的时间，比一个人怀胎十月陪伴孩子的时间还要长。它需要好几个月的时间。这是一项充满爱意的苦差事，但也有一些小贴士、小技巧和做法，可以让它变得容易得多，并让你从中获得极大的成就感。所以我们要进行一个
short break, but when we return, let me give you my five best tips for the very act of writing your dream novel. Two percent. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter and on my podcast. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress.
short break, but when we return, let me give you my five best tips for the very act of writing your dream novel. Two percent. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter and on my podcast. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress.|||短暂的休息，但等我们回来时，让我分享我关于撰写你梦想中的小说的五个最佳建议。百分之二。这就是当旁边有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客中。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中。我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，心理韧性、健身以及培养抗挫力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，带大家看透充斥在健康产业中不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为种子油生来就会引起炎症。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到惊恐的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the little. Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English.
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the little. Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English.|||把自己投入到一些艰难困苦中，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即 TWO%。在 iHeartRadio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在 VMA 颁奖典礼上拍打小姬姆（Little Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小姬姆到底有什么关系？你可以去《Look Back at it》播客中寻找答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。
Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence.
Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence.|||每期节目，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）畅谈80年代快克可卡因的节目。需要说明的是，84年对我很重要，不只是因为快克。我随时可以聊聊快克，但为了让大家知道我的意思。我的意思是，马克，这是我们第二期讨论快克了。所以我开始看出一条主线了。我们现在还把“艾滋病”这个话题摆上台面了。谢谢你帮我把话说完。
Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many.
Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many.|||是的。我认为没有比这更对黑人重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在 iHeartRadio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 look back at it。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》，我是主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师 Kear Games。为了迎接心理健康意识月，我将带来我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与众多
incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.
incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.|||不可思议的嘉宾展开对话。我说的是。特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它，却还在继续追逐，并且不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了一场关于输赢的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要，还是你做一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的。这也是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正成为一个好人。
Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test once.
Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test once.|||加入我 Kear Gaines 的行列，在我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》中，就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和人生目标展开真实的对话。打开免费的 iHeartRadio 应用。搜索 Learn the Hardway 并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克哈德（Clayton Eckerd）发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家庭法庭听证会暴露出她证词中明显的矛盾之处。这引发了一场长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。你在这份特定的检测中篡改了两次，对吧？我篡改了一次检测。
It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.|||这需要一大批网络侦探来侦破此案。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税都被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·阿莱斯皮（Greg Alespie）和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。
This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Okay, so I have five pretty large tips, five pretty broad tips for you. on how to write a book.
This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Okay, so I have five pretty large tips, five pretty broad tips for you. on how to write a book.|||这是《爱情陷阱》（Love Trap）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在 iHeartRadio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Love Trapped 播客。好的，我有五个相当宏大的建议，五个非常广泛的建议，关于如何写一本书。
So most books that you read are, unless it's like a short story, like a Claire Keegan kind of book, is probably going to be above 65,000 words. I think that was my minimum word count for my book. It ended up being, I think, around 85,000. But by that stage, like, I was on a roll. Like, there was no stopping me. I genuinely think at one point my publisher was like, please, please stop writing so much. like some of this is garbage.
So most books that you read are, unless it's like a short story, like a Claire Keegan kind of book, is probably going to be above 65,000 words. I think that was my minimum word count for my book. It ended up being, I think, around 85,000. But by that stage, like, I was on a roll. Like, there was no stopping me. I genuinely think at one point my publisher was like, please, please stop writing so much. like some of this is garbage.|||所以你读的大多数书，除非像短篇小说，比如克莱尔·吉甘（Claire Keegan）那种类型的书，字数大概都会在 65,000 字以上。我想那是我那本书的最低字数要求。到头来，我想大概达到了 85,000 字左右。但在那个阶段，就像，我文思如泉涌。就像，没有任何东西能阻止我。我真心觉得有那么一刻，我的出版社都在说：“求求你，求求你别写那么多了，有些内容简直是垃圾。”
Maybe they would deny that. But yes, there is a certain word limit that you want to get to. In order to get to that word limit, the first thing that you need to do is think before you write, but not too deeply. Basically what I mean by that is have some vague idea of where your story, where your novel, where your book is going to go.
Maybe they would deny that. But yes, there is a certain word limit that you want to get to. In order to get to that word limit, the first thing that you need to do is think before you write, but not too deeply. Basically what I mean by that is have some vague idea of where your story, where your novel, where your book is going to go.|||也许他们会否认这一点。但确实，你得达到某个字数限制。为了达到那个字数限制，你首先要做的是：动笔前先思考，但又不要想得太深。我这话的意思基本上是：对你的故事、你的小说、你的书将要走向何方，有一个大致模糊的概念。
Don't just expect that you can sit down and say, I've had this great idea, check, I know I need to write this book, check. I feel like it's writing itself, check. At some point, that book is going to stop writing itself and you are going to have to push hard. Like, I explained it to a friend recently is anyone who's ever written a book has gotten to this like large chasm, this large like empty space where you're on one side and where you want to go is the other side. And you have to find a way to ferry your book or get your book over that large space in between.
Don't just expect that you can sit down and say, I've had this great idea, check, I know I need to write this book, check. I feel like it's writing itself, check. At some point, that book is going to stop writing itself and you are going to have to push hard. Like, I explained it to a friend recently is anyone who's ever written a book has gotten to this like large chasm, this large like empty space where you're on one side and where you want to go is the other side. And you have to find a way to ferry your book or get your book over that large space in between.|||不要只是指望自己一坐下来就能说：我有了这个绝妙的点子，打勾；我知道我必须写这本书，打勾。我觉得这本书它自己会写呢，打勾。在某个时刻，那本书不会再自己往下写了，你必须得狠狠地推它一把。就像我最近向一位朋友解释的那样，任何写过书的人都会遇到这样一个巨大的深渊、这样一个巨大的空白地带，你站在这一边，而你想去的是另一边。你必须找到一种方法，把你的书运过去，或者让你的书跨越中间那片巨大的空白。
However you do it, it's a metaphor, you jump, you build a bridge, you find a detour, like there is going to be a difficult point. You can kind of avoid the difficulty of that snag by having some premeditated idea of where you think your story is going to go. So for me, I, like I explained, had that entire chapter outlined. So the day I started writing my book, which was January 28th, 2023. Yeah, January 28th, 2020, 23. I remember I'd just gotten back from Japan.
However you do it, it's a metaphor, you jump, you build a bridge, you find a detour, like there is going to be a difficult point. You can kind of avoid the difficulty of that snag by having some premeditated idea of where you think your story is going to go. So for me, I, like I explained, had that entire chapter outlined. So the day I started writing my book, which was January 28th, 2023. Yeah, January 28th, 2020, 23. I remember I'd just gotten back from Japan.|||不管你怎么做，这只是个比喻，你跳过去、你建一座桥、你找一条绕行路线，总之会有一个艰难的关卡。通过对你的故事走向有一个预先想好的构思，你可以在一定程度上避开这种卡壳的困难。所以对我来说，正如我所解释的，我把整章都做了大纲。所以当我开始写书的那天，也就是2023年1月28日。对，2023年1月28日。我记得我刚从日本回来。
Like, I knew what I had to write. And I knew how much of the book I needed to write every single week and month in order to get to my deadline. So my publisher had set a deadline and also set a personal deadline. that is something I would really encourage you to do if you are committed to writing a book. You can't just say I'm going to write a book and not give that an end date because you probably won't do it. It's like saying having a vague idea of like, I want to get fit, I want to get healthy, when, how, with who, whereabouts? Like you need to create structure around what is a huge endeavor and a huge goal. I would say you need at least four months to write.
Like, I knew what I had to write. And I knew how much of the book I needed to write every single week and month in order to get to my deadline. So my publisher had set a deadline and also set a personal deadline. that is something I would really encourage you to do if you are committed to writing a book. You can't just say I'm going to write a book and not give that an end date because you probably won't do it. It's like saying having a vague idea of like, I want to get fit, I want to get healthy, when, how, with who, whereabouts? Like you need to create structure around what is a huge endeavor and a huge goal. I would say you need at least four months to write.|||就像，我知道我必须写什么。我也知道为了赶上截止日期，我每周和每月必须写多少内容。所以我的出版社设定了一个截止日期，我自己也设定了一个个人截止日期。如果你立志写一本书，我真的非常鼓励你这样做。你不能只说一句“我要写本书”却不给它设定一个截止日期，因为你很可能不会去完成它。这就好比心里有个模糊的想法，比如“我想变苗条，我想变健康”，什么时候？怎么做？和谁一起？在哪里？就像你需要为一项巨大的工程和一个宏伟的目标建立结构一样。我要说的是，你至少需要四个月的时间来写
a book if you have, and a lot of us have full-time jobs. Like I obviously was still running the podcast as my full-time job alongside writing the book. Like four months is a push. Anywhere between four to 12 months. No more than 12 months though, because suddenly that becomes something that you can delay and something that you can kind of put off. I think the sweet spot is around six to seven months. That's kind of where you have enough of the urgency to write and to be actively involved in the writing process, but not enough urgency that you feel stressed out by this process and you feel stressed out by the end day.
a book if you have, and a lot of us have full-time jobs. Like I obviously was still running the podcast as my full-time job alongside writing the book. Like four months is a push. Anywhere between four to 12 months. No more than 12 months though, because suddenly that becomes something that you can delay and something that you can kind of put off. I think the sweet spot is around six to seven months. That's kind of where you have enough of the urgency to write and to be actively involved in the writing process, but not enough urgency that you feel stressed out by this process and you feel stressed out by the end day.|||一本书，如果你有的话，而且我们很多人都有全职工作。就像我显然一边写书，一边还要把播客当作全职工作来运营。四个月时间可以说是勉强凑合。四到十二个月之间都可以。不过不要超过十二个月，因为那样的话，它突然就会变成一件你可以拖延、可以一拖再拖的事情。我认为最佳时间点大约是六到七个月。在这个时候，你既有足够的紧迫感去写作并积极参与到写作过程中，又不会因为紧迫感过强而对这个过程感到压力山大，对截止日期感到焦虑。
Knowing I had a deadline in mind was really, really important for me. And it kind of leads me to tip number two, which is to create and commit to a routine. Commit to a routine that is X number of chapters per day, per week, per month, maybe a specific time in the day when you will sit down and write for two hours. For me, I did three days a week where my only job was to write. So I would do Sundays, Mondays and Tuesdays were my writing days. And then Wednesdays, Thursday, Fridays, and then the first half of Saturday was like when I would work.
Knowing I had a deadline in mind was really, really important for me. And it kind of leads me to tip number two, which is to create and commit to a routine. Commit to a routine that is X number of chapters per day, per week, per month, maybe a specific time in the day when you will sit down and write for two hours. For me, I did three days a week where my only job was to write. So I would do Sundays, Mondays and Tuesdays were my writing days. And then Wednesdays, Thursday, Fridays, and then the first half of Saturday was like when I would work.|||知道自己心里有个截止日期，对我和说真的非常非常重要。这自然而然地引出了我的第二条建议，那就是：建立并坚持一个常规。坚持一个设定了每天、每周或每月完成多少章节的常规，或者规定一天中的某个特定时间坐下来写上两小时。对我来说，我一周有三天时间，唯一的工作就是写作。所以我的写作日是周日、周一和周二。然后周三、周四、周五，以及周六的上半天，就是我用来工作的时间。
And I found that really, really worked for me because it allowed me to kind of compartmentalize and, keep the two distinct things that I was doing separate because they also were kind of similar. So I just felt like it would be very easy if I hadn't done that to flick from one to the other to one to the other and feel like I was losing my mind. So that's how I structured it. I know people do it differently. There's a very famous writer called Murakami. What's some of the stuff that he's written? Oh, I cannot remember men talking about women.
我发现这真的非常适合我，因为它让我能够把事情进行某种程度的划分，把我正在做的两件截然不同的事情分开，因为这两件事其实也有点相似。所以我觉得，如果不这样做的话，我会非常容易在它们之间反复横跳，觉得自己快要疯了。这就是我的规划方式。我知道别人可能有不同的做法。有一位非常著名的作家叫村上春树。他写过哪些作品？哦，我记不清了，好像有一本是写男人谈论女人的。
I think is maybe one of them. Just look him up. He's written some fantastic things. Like, it's escaping my mind right now. But my dad was telling me how when this man is committed to writing a new novel, how he does it is that he's really into running, right? And he uses running as a reward. So he says, I have to write 15 pages before I'm allowed to run.
我觉得这可能是其中一本吧。你们可以去查查他。他写过一些非常棒的作品。真的，我一下子想不起来了。但我爸爸曾跟我讲过，当这个人决定写一部新小说时，他是怎么做的呢？他非常喜欢跑步，对吧？他把跑步当成一种奖励。所以他说，我必须写完15页，才能去跑步。
That kind of positive reinforcement reward cycle is something that really works. is something that really works for people saying, okay, well, I'm not going to go see my friends until I've done my 1,000 words for the day, until I've done my chapter for the week. I can't go out on a Saturday unless this is done. I know that feels quite clinical and disciplined, and maybe that's not how you see storytelling and storywriting, and obviously this is just my perspective. So you can do it however you want, but I will say having that kind of discipline is something that maybe we're missing a little bit.
这种正向强化的奖励机制确实非常管用。这种方法对很多人来说真的很有效，比如他们会对自己说：“好吧，在写完今天的一千字、完成这周的章节之前，我是不会去见朋友的。”“不把这个完成，我周六绝不出门。”我知道这听起来相当死板和严苛，也许这并不是你看待讲故事和小说创作的方式，当然这只是我个人的观点。所以你想怎么做都可以，但我要说的是，具备这种纪律性正是我们现在可能有点欠缺的东西。
Think about the time when you were most productive in your life. It was probably when you were in primary school or high school, or in college when you had structures to your day, you had timelines, you had end dates and deadlines and goals that you had to meet. You were able to manage so many things because you provided your brain with a goal-based environment and a goal-winning structure. in which it can operate easier. The other thing is that writing a book is still fun, right?
想想你一生中最有效率的那段时光。那可能是在你上小学、中学、或者大学的时候，当时你的日程很有条理，有时间表，有最终期限、截止日期，还有必须达成的目标。你之所以能处理那么多事情，是因为你为大脑提供了一个以目标为导向的环境，以及一个便于它高效运转的激励结构。另一件事是，写书其实还是很有趣的，对吧？
For all the discussions around creating a routine and being disciplined and commitment and blah, blah, blah. It's just that it's a unique kind of fun called type 2 fun. So someone explained this to me the other day. There are three different types of fun, type 1 fun, type 1 fun, type 2 fun, type 3 fun. So type 1 fun is stuff that's just always going to be a blast, like a trampoline park, like a comedy show, like things that are just innately enjoyable without requiring too much effort from you. Type 2 fun is the kind of fun that writing a book is or running a marathon.
抛开关于建立常规、保持纪律、承担承诺之类的一切讨论不谈，这其实是一种独特的乐趣，叫做“二级乐趣”（Type 2 fun）。前几天有人向我解释了这个概念。乐趣分为三种不同的类型：一级乐趣、二级乐趣、三级乐趣。一级乐趣就是那些永远都会让人嗨翻天的活动，比如蹦床公园、脱口秀，也就是那些天生就能带来快乐、不需要你付出太多努力的事情。二级乐趣则是写书或跑马拉松这种体验所带来的乐趣。
It's not necessarily all that fun when you're doing it, but it's fun at various points when you can look back and see how far you've come or see the outcome of your hard work or get to read what you've written. Type 3 fun is just not fun at all. Type 3 fun is the kind of fun that none of us really want to get into hiking Everest, like ending up doing things that are very, very dangerous or going to actually leave you very scared, lonely, incapable. They're not even fun in hindsight.
在你进行的过程中，它未必有多好玩，但当你在各个阶段回首过去，看到自己取得了多大的进步，看到了辛勤耕花的结果，或者读到自己写的东西时，它就会变得很有趣。三级乐趣则是一点都不好玩。三级乐趣是那种我们谁都不想去尝试的事情，比如徒步攀登珠穆朗玛峰，结果陷入非常非常危险的境地，最终让你感到恐惧、孤独、无能为力。它们甚至在事后回忆起来也一点都不好玩。
Like there was the potential for type 2 fun, but that potential wasn't there. Lean into the type 2 fun of this moment. Yes, writing a book is hard. If it wasn't hard, everyone would. would be doing it. There is a reason that not everyone writes books. That's also a really enjoyable and romantic part of the process. I think it is quite beautiful that you are committing your brain and your body and your mind and your soul to not a sprint, a marathon of creativity, knowing that you're unsure of the outcome, but knowing even more so that this is something that you need to do.
就好像本来可能存在二级乐趣的潜力，但那种潜力根本不存在。去享受当下这种二级乐趣吧。没错，写书很难。如果不难的话，每个人都会去写了。不是每个人都写书是有原因的。这也是创作过程中非常美妙、非常浪漫的一部分。我觉得这其实非常美好：你将自己的大脑、身体、思想和灵魂投入到这场充满未知的创意马拉松中（它可不是短跑），虽然你对结果感到不确定，但你更清楚地知道，这是你必须去做的一件事。
I will also say right at your best times, not at the ideal time. time. So I definitely feel that there is this pull and sense that we need to do our work during business hours, even if what your work is, is completely self-driven and self-motivated. Like, if you're writing a novel, you need to be writing between nine to five. That's delusional. Not everyone, like the whole nine to five system is quite delusional. The fact that everyone thinks our peak operating times is during such a limited period of hours is ridiculous. Every single one of us actually has our own unique circadium and cortisol and arousal rhythm. And we also have our peak attention and peak performance times that are going to occur at unique points in the day that probably differ from most other people.
我还要说的是，要在你状态最好的时候写作，而不是在所谓的“理想时间”。我绝对能感觉到，社会上存在着这样一种压力和观念：我们必须在工作时间内工作，哪怕你的工作完全是自我驱动和自我激励的。比如，如果你在写小说，你就必须在早九晚五之间写作。这太荒谬了。不是每个人——整套早九晚五的制度本身就很荒谬。每个人都认为我们注意力最集中的巅峰期是在这样一个有限的时间段内，这简直太可笑了。实际上，我们每个人都有自己独特的昼夜节律、皮质醇水平和清醒节律。我们也有各自注意力最集中、表现最好的黄金时间，这些时间通常出现在一天的特定时刻，很可能与大多数人都不一样。
For me, writing at 9pm, oh my God, it was like the words were fire. It was like I could not stop these thoughts from like pouring out of me. Writing at 10 a.m. when everyone was suggesting I should be at my peak productivity, it was miserable. Like I genuinely felt like I could not keep my eyes open. I think I ended up realizing that the best times for me to write were between 7 to 9 a.m., 2 to 5 p.m. and 9 to 11 p.m. obviously that's only six hours. There were times when I did have to push myself during those days that I was writing. But if I had the option to do other things during that time, you best believe I was taking them
对我来说，晚上9点写作，天哪，那些字句简直就像在燃烧。我感觉自己根本无法阻止这些思绪从脑海中喷涌而出。而早上10点当所有人都建议我应该处于效率巅峰时去写作，那简直是一种折磨。我当时真的觉得自己的眼皮都抬不起来。我想我后来意识到，我最适合写作的时间其实是早上7点到9点、下午2到5点以及晚上9点到11点。显然，加起来一共才六个小时。在写作的那些日子里，有时我确实需要逼自己一把。但如果那个时间我有别的选择，你可以笃定我一定会去做别的。
because I just knew that I was better well spent on doing some of these other less intense tasks during this time than doing them when they were perhaps more expected. Like in the morning or the evening when I was going to be more primed for writing. So pay attention to when you feel most invigorated by your book, you feel most in a flow state, you feel like the whole process is a lot more effortless. I will also say adventure in between times where you are really committed to writing. So whether that means taking your writing to a retreat, going out of town for a little bit, booking a secluded Airbnb by yourself and just committing to writing for the weekend, and then in between. sessions, going for nature walks, going outdoors, going to wineries, seeing friends. Our brain thrives on novelty and newness. And especially those of us with a creative mind,
因为我很清楚，把时间花在做那些没那么剧烈的其他任务上，要比在那些预期应该写作的时间（比如早晨或夜晚，那时我本来更适合写作）去做更有价值。所以，要关注你什么时候对你的书最充满热情，什么时候最能进入心流状态，什么时候让你觉得整个创作过程毫不费力。我还要说的是，在你真正投入写作的间隙，去经历一些冒险吧。不管是把你的写作带去一个静修营，去外地小住一段时间，独自预定一个偏僻的爱彼迎（Airbnb）并承诺自己周末只管写作，还是在写作间隙去大自然中散步、去户外、去酒庄、见见朋友。我们的大脑对新鲜事物和新奇感有着极大的渴求。尤其是我们这些拥有创造性思维的人，
we need more of that than the average person. That novelty and newness is how your brain creates new connections. It's also how it creates new ideas and how it turns abstract thinking into concrete thinking, into creative thinking. You know, someone who is sitting in a plain, room is not going to write anywhere near a greater book as someone who is writing that same novel in the countryside or somewhere where there is stimulation and new experiences and new encounters and human interactions that can inspire them. So make sure you do not lose your need for novelty and freshness and adventure in the disciplinary routine of writing a book. In fact, I think the more fun you have in between writing.
我们对这种需求比普通人更强烈。这种新奇感正是你大脑建立新连接的方式。这也是它产生新想法的方式，是将抽象思维转化为具体思维、转化为创造性思维的途径。你知道的，一个坐在空洞房间里的人，绝对写不出在乡村或者在充满刺激、新体验、新遭遇以及能激发灵感的社会交往的环境中创作出的那种伟大的小说。所以，千万不要在写书这种纪律严明的常规中，丢掉了你对新鲜感、新奇事物和冒险的渴望。事实上，我认为你在写作间隙玩得越开心，
sessions, the better that book is actually going to end up being. This next tip is probably my favorite one and it is also the tip that I learnt the hardest of always. And it is that sometimes you have to kill your darlings. Sometimes you write something that you think is really, really good or that isn't actually that good, but it took so much of you to write it that you think it deserves a place in your final manuscript. There was a particular chapter in person in progress that did not make it to the final print edition that I spent two weeks on.
那本书最终呈现出来的效果其实就会越好。接下来的这个建议可能是我最喜欢的，同时也是我付出最惨痛代价才学到的教训。那就是：有时你必须“杀死你的挚爱”（删掉你最喜爱但累赘的内容）。有时候你会写出一些自以为非常非常棒，或者其实没那么好、但因为倾注了你大量心血而让你觉得它理应在最终书稿中占有一席之地的东西。在《进度条》（Person in Progress）中，有一个特定的章节我花了两个星期去写，结果却没有进入最终的印刷版。
Two weeks on one chapter and it didn't even make it. And here's the thing. From the very beginning, I knew it was a bad chapter. I knew the flow wasn't there. I knew the idea wasn't there. I knew the commitment wasn't there. I knew there was just nothing for me in this chapter.
为了一个章节花了两周时间，结果连最终版都没进。事情是这样的。从一开始我就知道这是一个烂章节。我知道行文不够流畅。我知道这个想法不够成熟。我知道投入的精力不对。我知道这一章里根本没有打动我自己的东西。
It didn't belong in the book, but I was forcing it and forcing it and I had to write it. And then when my editor was like, this is not a good chapter, I'm going to cut it. I was like, you can't because that took so much for me. Even though I know it's not good, it took so much for me. I don't regret writing it. I don't regret putting all my thoughts down onto the page because maybe it could have turned out amazing. But at some stage, you will have to kill plot lines, kill characters, change characters, kill storylines, kill certain arcs because they just aren't working.
它根本不属于这本书，但我一直在硬着头皮写、硬着头皮写。后来当我的编辑说：“这一章写得不好，我要把它删掉。”我的反应是：“你不能删，因为我为它付出了太多心血。”尽管我知道它写得不好，但我付出了那么多。我不后悔写下它。我不后悔把所有的想法都倾注在纸面上，因为也许它当时真的有可能变成神来之笔。但在某个阶段，你必须狠心砍掉一些情节线、砍掉一些人物、修改人物、砍掉一些故事线、砍掉某些人物弧光，因为它们就是行不通。
You're going to have to kill your darlings. It is better to have had a first draft and to have committed to a bad idea and killed off that idea than committed to no idea at all. So if there is an instinct to write something, even if it's difficult, still write it. You can always cut it and remove it. And yes, it might feel like a loss, but it also means that the better parts of your book speak louder. so don't be afraid to go back and say, yeah, this probably wasn't my best work.
你必须学会舍弃心爱的内容。比起没有产生任何想法，能够写出初稿、勇敢尝试一个糟糕的主意并最终将其淘汰，其实要好得多。所以，如果你有一种想要写点什么的冲动，哪怕这很难，也尽管去写吧。你随时可以剪裁和删掉它。是的，这可能会让你觉得是一种损失，但这同时也意味着你书中那些更精彩的部分会显得更加耀眼。所以，不要害怕回过头去说：“是的，这可能确实不是我最好的作品。”
Something better is going to take this chapter or this sentences or this storyline's place. Here are my two final tips. This second last one is something we've already spoken about, but I want to really, really nail this point home. Write this book for you first, not for anybody else. What I mean by that is that when you are writing, your novel, your book. There is a great deal of pressure and an instinct, I think, to constantly be ruminating and trying to dissect what you think the reader would want to read or hear or see happen next.
会有更精彩的东西来取代这一章、这些句子或者这条故事线。接下来是我的最后两条建议。倒数第二条其实我们刚才已经聊过了，但我真的很想、很想把这个观点彻底讲透。写这本书，首先是为了你自己，而不是为了任何人。我的意思是，当你正在创作你的小说、你的书时。
There is an obsession with how this novel, this book is going to be perceived. And that intense awareness of other people's perception can mean that you write a book that is, not actually in your own voice and not actually something that you actually wanted to write because you were so fearful of other people's disapproval. A bad book that you enjoyed writing and that sounds like you is better than an okay book that sounds like anyone else could have written it. And it's better than an okay book that everyone's like, eh, about. Write this book in your style, even if you think they might not like it,
你会承受巨大的压力，并且会有一种本能，总是去反复琢磨和试图剖析你认为读者会想要阅读、听到或看到接下来发生什么。人们总是过分痴迷于这本小说、这本书将会如何被外界看待。而这种对他人看法的强烈敏感，可能会导致你写出来的书根本不是你自己的真实声音，也不是你真正想写的东西，因为你太害怕遭到别人的非议了。一本你写得很享受、听起来很有你个人风格的烂书，也强过一本听起来像是任何人都能写出来的平庸之作；而且它也比那种让所有人觉得“也就那样吧”的平庸之作要好得多。请用你自己的风格来写这本书，哪怕你认为他们可能不会喜欢，
even if you think there are decisions that you are making that they wouldn't make, like this is your book at the end of the day. You know, you could finish writing this manuscript and only one person could buy it and you actually haven't written the book that you wanted to write. And then in the future, 20 years down the line, when you dig up an old copy and you find it and you're reading it, you're thinking, ugh, like, why did I do that? Why did I try and sound so smart?
哪怕你觉得你所做的决定是他们绝不会做的——说到底，这是你的书。要知道，你可能最终完成了这本手稿，结果只有一个人买单，而你实际上甚至连自己真正想写的书都没有写出来。然后到了未来，20年后的某一天，当你翻出一本旧书副本，找到它并读起来时，你心里会想：天哪，我当时为什么会那样写？我为什么非要装得那么聪明？
Why did I try and sound so pretentious? Why did I use words I didn't know? Why did I say things I didn't actually believe in? Oh, it was because of this arbitrary ghost-like amalgamation of a reader who I don't even know or care about, but whose fantasy opinion I was gearing towards. This is your book. The act of writing it in itself is a healing, beautiful, sacred practice. Who cares if no one likes it? If you like it, if you had fun writing it, that is all that matters. I would also call you to constantly reflect on the why. Like I said, there will come a point where there is a chasm. There is a drop-off.
我为什么非要显得那么矫揉造作？我为什么要用那些我根本不认识的词？我为什么要说那些我实际上根本不相信的话？哦，原来是因为一个虚无缥缈的、像幽灵一般的“理想读者”的聚合体——我甚至根本不认识他、也不在乎他，却为了迎合他那虚构的审美而委曲求全。这是你的书。写作这一行为本身就是一种治愈的、美好的、神圣的修行。谁会在乎有没有人喜欢呢？如果你自己喜欢，如果你在写作过程中感到快乐，这才是最重要的一切。我还要呼吁大家，要不断地反思你的“初心（为什么）”。就像我说的，在写作过程中总会遇到一道鸿沟，会出现断层。
There is a space that you have to bridge to get to the other side of writing this piece of work. The thing that will actually really help you get there is why do I actually want to write this? What is my intrinsic motivation for producing this piece of work? I can't give you that motivation. I can't give you the answer to that question. There are a few different whys. Maybe you're wise. that this is a story that you feel needs to be on a page for you to have closure. Maybe your why is that this is the book that you wish that you had and you wish that you would read. Maybe your why is that you are just so endlessly fascinated by the story or that you've always wanted to be a writer and this feels part of your destiny.
会有这样一个空间，你需要去跨越它，才能抵达这部作品的彼岸。而真正能帮到你、让你坚持到最后的原因是：我究竟为什么要写这个？我创作这部作品的内在动机是什么？我无法把那个动机赋予你。我无法给你这个问题的标准答案。每个人的“初心”都有所不同。也许你的初心是：这是一个你觉得必须写成文字、好让自己释怀的故事。也许你的初心是：这是你一直梦想拥有、却求而不得的你想读的书。也许你的初心是：你对这个故事有着无尽的着迷，或者你一直渴望成为一名作家，而这感觉就像是你命中注定的一部分。
We're all going to have a different motivation. Make sure you are clear on what yours is and make sure you continuously reflect on it. For me, my why was, this is the book that I really needed and I wish that people had been more honest about certain topics that went into the book. I didn't really find that honesty and anything else I was reading. My other why was that I was doing it for my future self. You know, since I was a child, I really wanted to be a writer and I really wanted to be an author. But I also knew that my older self really would have wanted to know what I was thinking and feeling at this point in my life.
我们都会有不同的动机。确保你清楚自己的初心是什么，并确保你不断地反思它。对我来说，我的初心是：这就是我真正需要的书，我希望当初能有人对书中涉及的某些话题更加坦诚。我在当时阅读的其他任何东西里都没有找到这种坦诚。我的另一个初心是，我是在为未来的自己写作。你知道的，打从记事起，我真的很想成为一名作家，我真的很想成为一名书作者。但我也深知，未来的我一定会很想知道我在人生的这个阶段都在想些什么、感受着什么。
And although I didn't end up using that diary idea I was talking about at the beginning, person in progress is, it's not biographical, but there definitely are biographical elements to it and stories that I think my future self would really get a kick out of reading. And I think that this was an endeavor
尽管我最终并没有采用一开始提到的日记那个点子，《进度条》并不是一本传记，但里面确实包含了一些传记元素，还有一些我认为未来的自己在阅读时会觉得很有趣、很有代入感的故事。我认为这是一次我深知
that I knew was always going to be worthwhile, even if no one bought it, because I would have the opportunity to say, I did that, I did the hard thing. I wrote a book. at some stage in my life, I had enough good thoughts, or at least what I thought were good thoughts, to put 85,000 words down on a page and print it off. And if nothing else, give it to family and friends.
无论有没有人买单都绝对值得的尝试，因为我将有机会说：我做到了，我完成了那件难事。我写了一本书。在我人生中的某个阶段，我有足够多的好想法——或者至少是我自认为的好想法——把85,000个字倾注在纸面上并把它打印了出来。哪怕别的什么都没有，至少还能把它送给家人和朋友。
So that was my longstanding motivation. Okay, we are going to take a short break, but when we return, I want to answer some of the questions you guys asked me over on Instagram about how to write a book, very, very simple question, the one we've been talking about this entire time, but I wanted to hear from you guys and your specific questions. So stay tuned. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers,
好了，我们要稍作休息，但等我们回来后，我想回答一些你们在Instagram上向我提出的关于如何写书的问题。这是一个非常、非常简单的问题——我们一直在探讨的就是这个，但我想听听你们大家的具体问题。所以请锁定频道。2%。这就是当旁边有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在当今这个奇特现代世界中培养精神韧性、强健体魄以及构建复原力的科学。我将与作家、
researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，带大家拨开那些主导健康产业的、不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学迷雾。我们曾经真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你终将浴火重生，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。
Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast.
欢迎收听《2%》。名字是数字 2，后面跟 Percent，在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方都可以收听。还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在 VMA 颁奖典礼上双击（袭胸）小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什不关心黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。
I'm Sam Jek. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. clearly, 84 is big to me not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know.
我是萨姆·杰克（Sam Jek）。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ（Alex English）。每期节目中，我们都会精选一个历史时刻，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期邀请了马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）的节目，他大谈特谈80年代的“快克”可卡因。显然，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时都能聊一整天关于快克的话题，不过想让大家知道这一点。
I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast.
我是说，马克，这已经是我们第二期节目讨论快克了。所以我开始看出这里面有一条贯穿始终的脉络了。我们现在甚至还把艾滋病也摆到台面上来了。谢谢你帮我把话说完。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。欢迎在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts
or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field
或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》（难走的路），我是你的主持人、也是你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯（Keer Games）。为了致敬心理健康意识月，我将带来我自己在心理健康领域十多年的丰富经验，
and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it, and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch.
以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾进行的深入对话。我说的正是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，在我们追求某样东西的过程中，我们太过于陷入追逐本身，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐，甚至不知道什么时候才算“够了”。因为人们总是盯着记分牌。
Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust.
生活变成了关于输赢的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得作为一个在世上活着的好人很重要吗？你成为一个好人，是因为你害怕吗？因为兄弟，这可是两种完全不同的动机。绝对是的。这是两个截然不同的信任层级。
I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free. iHeartRadio app search Learn the Hard Way and listen now.
我希望你能真正发自内心地做一个好人。快来加入我基尔·盖恩斯的行列，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，我们将就疗愈、成长、父爱、压力和使命展开真实的对话。打开免费的 iHeartRadio App，搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。
In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth.
2023年，前“单身汉”明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Echard）发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了他故事中惊人的前后矛盾。这开启了一场历时多年的、旨在证明真相的法庭之战。
You doctored this particular test twice in someone's, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern.
你曾经两次篡改某人的这份特定检测结果，对吗？我篡改过一次检测结果。这需要一支互联网侦探大军才能破案。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税都被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们揭露了一个令人不安的模式。
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gregalespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
还有两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·莱斯皮安（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我的天哪，我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬（Stephanie Young）。这是《Love Trap》（爱情陷阱）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于要承担后果了。
Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over. until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Okay, so you guys know this is a new thing that we're doing where I get you guys to ask your questions about any episodes or ideas that we are discussing. And today, the questions had to do with the act and the process of writing.
女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有诈骗罪。在亚利桑那州，
This first question comes from Lauren. how do you know where to start? Now I think for me that was quite easy. I did initially start with the first chapter. However, as I went along, I started jumping between sections. So person in progress has four sections. Each of them are very different from the last. One of them's about work.
正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trap》播客。好了，你们都知道这是我们正在做的一个新尝试，我会让大家针对我们讨论过的任何剧集或观点提出你们的问题。今天的核心问题都围绕着写作的行为和过程展开。这第一个问题来自劳伦。怎么知道该从哪里开始呢？现在我觉得对我来说这其实挺容易的。我最初确实是从第一章开始写的。不过，随着写作的深入，我开始在不同章节之间跳来跳去。《进度条》一书共有四个部分。每一部分都与前一部分截然不同。其中一部分是关于工作的。
One of them's about relationships. One of them's about healing. One of them's about everyday 20-something experiences. I would just choose the chapter that I felt I most wanted to write that day until I ended up at the chapter at the very end that I at least wanted to write, which ended up being the one on heartbreak. But how I would answer this question is that where you need to start is where you feel most called to start and most passionate to write about.
一部分是关于人际关系的。一部分是关于疗愈的。还有一部分是关于20多岁人群的日常经历的。我当时就是选择那些我那天最想写的章节去写，直到最后只剩下我最不想写的那一章——也就是关于心碎的那一章。不过，如果让我来回答这个问题，你的起点应该是：你最感召唤、最充满创作热情去写的地方。
What is the chapter, the section, the component of the book that you feel most exhilarated by? You know, I heard about this author through my friend Alex, actually, who runs basic bitch book club. and she was telling me how one of these authors, and she was telling me that one of the authors of her favorite book actually started writing the book at the end, like in the last three chapters. So the last chapters that we read when we read that book were the first chapters she wrote. Because the story she was telling, the reason she wanted to tell it was because it had a specific ending that she really wanted to capture. and then she worked backwards from there. Some people like to begin at the very beginning.
书中最让你感到兴奋的章节、部分或组件是什么？说实话，我是通过我的朋友亚历克斯（Alex）——她经营着“基本婊子读书俱乐部”（Basic Bitch Book Club）——才听说这位作家的。她告诉我，她最喜欢的书的其中一位作家，其实是从书的结尾开始写的，也就是最后三个章节。所以，当我们阅读那本书时读到的最后几个章节，其实是她动笔写的最初章节。因为她所讲述的故事、她想要讲述这个故事的原因，是因为它有一个她极力想要捕捉的特定结局，
I don't think that's necessarily always the best way for everyone. Start where you feel most called to begin. And if you don't know where to start, start by just fleshing out some key ideas. Start by maybe even writing a mini chapter from someone else's perspective on the main character and what they look like. Someone once gave me this brilliant writing exercise
然后她从那个结局开始倒推。有些人喜欢从头开始。我觉得这未必永远是对所有人都最好的方法。从你最感召唤、最想开始的地方动笔。如果你不知道该从哪里开始，那就从丰满一些核心想法开始。甚至可以从别人的视角为主角写一个小剧场，描写主角的长相和特质。曾经有人教过我一个极好的写作练习，
if you want to flesh out your main character or a character in your book more, imagine what someone would see or know about them from encountering them in a coffee shop. So write a mini chapter from the perspective of a third party, watching, learning, looking at your main character. It might not end up in the book. It probably won't end up in the book, but it will give you more of an idea of where to go from there and more of an inspiration. This next question, I love, how to finish a draft.
如果你想让你的主角或者书中的某个角色更加血肉丰满，你可以想象一下，如果有人在咖啡馆里偶遇他们，会看到或了解到他们什么。所以，请试着从第三方观察者的视角写一个小章节，去观察、了解、注视你的主角。这段内容可能最终不会收录进书中。它大概率不会出现在书中，但它会给你提供更多灵感，让你知道接下来该往哪个方向写。接下来的这个问题我非常喜欢：如何完成初稿？
keep rewriting the first three chapters. Oofed, I totally get this. If you're a bit of a perfectionist like myself, it can feel like you cannot move on from a chapter unless it is up to your incredibly high standards. I don't think that's necessarily a bad thing. I think it shows care and love and appreciation for your work. However, I do understand that it's frustrating
总是忍不住反复重写前三章。天哪，我太懂这种感受了。如果你像我一样有点完美主义倾向，你可能会觉得，除非某一章达到了你高得离谱的标准，否则你根本无法继续写下去。我觉得这未必是一件坏事。我觉得这体现了你对作品的关心、热爱与珍视。不过，我也完全理解这种做法让人感到沮丧，
and that if you have a book that's going to end up being 30 chapters and you've only written three, you kind of want to get the ball rolling. My biggest tip for this is to put those three chapters aside, put them in one document, start chapter four in a new document, so that there is not the pressure or the kind of urge to go back and scroll up a little bit and just start changing words here and there or, you know, finding synonyms or antonyms for this word or that word or changing very, very minor things. Pretend that you are starting the book from chapter four. and start writing it from there.
因为如果一本书最后会有30章，而你才写了3章，你肯定会迫不及待地想让进度推进起来。我针对这一点最大的建议是：把那前三章放到一边，把它们放在一个单独的文档里，在另一个新文档里开始写第四章。这样你就不会背负着那种想要回过头往上滚屏、然后开始这改改那改改、或者到处找同义词反义词、又或者修改极其微小细节的强迫感或冲动。假装你现在是从第四章开始写这本书，
Another great way to basically force yourself to write is to put on a 15-minute timer or a 20-minute timer and say, this does not have to be good. This doesn't have to even be comprehensible. I'm just going to write for 15 minutes and see what comes up, and see what flows through me. I think the roadblock that you are facing is one of perfectionism, and I also think it's one of a fear of failure,
并从那里继续写下去。另一个强迫自己写作的好方法是：设定一个15分钟或20分钟的定时器，然后对自己说：“这不需要写得很好。甚至不需要逻辑通顺。我只是要写上15分钟，看看会迸发出什么，看看有什么思绪从我心中流淌出来。”我觉得你目前面临的绊脚石是一种完美主义，同时我也认为这是一种对失败的恐惧，
which often they go hand in hand. giving yourself space and room for whatever you're writing to be imperfect, maybe not that great, will also provide you with a lot of freedom to just make mistakes and to make creative errors that actually end up being creative doorways. Here's our next question. I've always wanted to write, but I feel like no one cares about what I have to say. This is kind of similar to this question from Ella. How do you push through imposter syndrome?
而这两者通常是相辅相成的。给你正在写的任何内容留出空间和余地，允许它不够完美、甚至可能没那么好，这也会为你带来巨大的自由度，让你敢于犯错、敢于犯下那些最终会成为创意之门的创作错误。来看我们的下一个问题：我一直想写作，但我觉得根本没人关心我要说什么。这其实和埃拉（Ella）的这个问题有点像：如何克服虚假综合征（冒名顶替综合征）？
Will anyone read this? maybe no one will read it. I do think people will read it firstly. I will say that. But maybe they won't. My question is, why is that a bad thing? Why is it that every single form of creation has to receive outside acknowledgement and can't just be for our own, for, you know, the sake of it, for our own internal pleasure and enjoyment of the activity? That aside, because I know that's quite a nihilistic view of things and quite a pessimistic view and maybe not for everyone. If you are thinking, why should I write a book?
会有人读这本书吗？也许真的没人读吧。不过首先，我依然觉得人们是会读的。我得这么说。但也许不会。我的问题是：这为什么是一件坏事呢？为什么每一种形式的创作都必须要获得外界的认可，而不能仅仅为了我们自己、为了纯粹的乐趣、为了我们内心的愉悦和享受这项活动本身呢？抛开这一点不谈——因为我知道这是一种相当虚无主义的观点，也是一种相当悲观的视角，可能并不适合所有人。如果你在想：“我为什么要写书？
No one cares what I have to say. No one cares what anyone has to say until they say it. The question I always like to ask people is, why not you? Genuinely, why not you? And you might come up with a couple of reasons. All of those reasons are your self-doubt trying to sabotage you. And when self-doubt tries to sabotage you,
根本没人关心我要说什么。”在一个人开口说话之前，没有人会关心任何人要说什么。我最喜欢问大家的一个问题是：为什么不是你？说真的，为什么不能是你呢？你可能会想出几个理由。而所有这些理由，其实都是你的自我怀疑在试图破坏你。当自我怀疑试图破坏你的时候，
It's actually trying to protect you. It doesn't want you to get hurt. It doesn't want you to feel embarrassed. It doesn't want you to feel rejected. And so it will keep you in the safest place, which is the place where you are doing nothing. Every single person I think who has written a book has thought, and I've definitely thought this, like, why am I doing this?
它其实是在试图保护你。它不想让你受到伤害。它不想让你感到尴尬。它不想让你感到被拒绝。所以它会把你留在最安全的那个地方——也就是什么都不做的地方。我想每一个写过书的人都曾想过——我绝对也这样想过——比如：“我到底在干什么？
No one cares what I have to say. No one's going to buy a copy. Everyone's going to hate it. And then I just remind myself that if that's the case, I still got so much out of it up. up until this point. And everyone had to write their first draft. Everyone had to put out their first book. Every single person, every single author that you admire has had those same thoughts. And they still were committed to writing it when they were a nobody, when no one knew who they
根本没人关心我要说什么。没人会买一本。所有人都会讨厌它。”然后我就会提醒自己，即便真是那样，我在这个过程中依然收获了如此之多的成长。而且每个人都必须写出他们的初稿。每个人都必须出版他们的第一本书。每一个你所钦佩的人、每一个作者，都曾有过同样的思想斗争。而当他们还是个无名小卒、当没有人知道他们是谁的时候，他们依然坚定地投入到写作中，
were. And their novels, their books, their manuscripts ended up changing lives. So I hope that helps you feel better about either alternative. So this final question is, was actually a really, really common one. How do you go about getting a publisher slash agent? What's the process like and what are the chances of being rejected? Oh right. I'm not going to lie. The chances of being rejected are quite high. However, rejection is a doorway. Rejection is redirection. Rejection is a mirror. Rejection is a motivator. Rejection is not something to be afraid of. Here's the other thing. You can get rejected by the same publishing house like six or seven times. Like they might say go away, fix this, bring it back. We still don't like it. Go away, fix this, bring it back. Just because something was rejected in its
最终，他们的小说、他们的书、他们的手稿改变了无数人的生命。所以，我希望这能让你对这两种可能性都感觉好受一些。那么最后一个问题，其实是一个非常、非常常见的问题：该如何寻找出版商或代理人？这个过程是怎样的？被拒绝的概率有多大？哦，天哪。老实说，我不会对你们撒谎，被拒绝的概率其实相当高。不过，拒绝也是一扇门。拒绝是一次方向的重构。拒绝是一面镜子。拒绝是一个催化剂。拒绝并不可怕。还有一件事。你可能会被同一家出版商拒绝六到七次。比如他们可能会说：“走开，把这个改改再拿来。我们还是不喜欢。走开，改好了再拿来。”仅仅因为某个东西在它当前的形态下被拒绝了，并不意味着它以后还会被拒绝。并不意味着它会被别人拒绝。
current form doesn't mean it's going to be rejected again. It doesn't mean it's going to be rejected by someone else. There have been so many examples of authors who have gone on to write incredible books who have been rejected many, many times. And I'm sure those publishing houses were sitting there being like, oh, we really, we really screwed up. We really dropped the ball on that one. As long as you believe in yourself, I know that you are going to work hard and you are going to find new avenues to get your work out there. When it comes to finding a publisher, a couple of tips that I would give is go to heaps of industry events, cold email, ask other established authors or people that you know who have written books to read your manuscript.
有太多这样的例子了：许多后来写出惊世骇俗之作的作家，在起步阶段都曾被拒绝过无数次。我敢肯定，那些出版商当时一定坐在那里懊恼地说：“哦，我们真的是搞砸了，我们在那个项目上彻底失手了。”只要你相信自己，我知道你一定会付出努力，并且会找到新的途径把你的作品推向世界。当谈到寻找出版商时，我可以给出的几条建议是：去参加大量的行业活动，发冷邮件（Cold Email），请其他成熟的作家或你认识的写过书的人来阅读你的手稿。
Try not to focus on needing a publisher to write, just write the thing. I do feel like having a book that's already written is perhaps a selling point because they can tell if they like it or not and they can kind of get a sense of where they might want to take that initial draft. And remember, there are so many ways to be published. I'd also say start submitting chapters to magazines, to journals, to literary magazines as well, just try and get your work out there and know that the right people will find it. It might just not be your time now. It doesn't mean that your time isn't going to come.
尽量不要把精力过分集中在“必须先找到出版商才能写作”这件事上，先把书写出来再说。我确实觉得，拥有一本已经写好的书可能是一个卖点，因为他们可以一眼看出自己是否喜欢，并且能大致感受到他们可能想对这个初稿做怎样的调整。记住，出版的方式有千万种。我还要建议大家：开始向杂志、期刊以及文学杂志投稿章节，尽量让你的作品传播出去，并相信对的人总会发现它。现在可能只是还没到你的时机。这并不意味着你的好运永远不会到来。
I think that's all we have time for today. Thank you so much all of you for being so invested as to make it this far into the episode. If you did make it this far, I want you to leave the name of the book that has changed your life. What is the book that you are so glad someone wrote? And that it feels like they wrote it just for you. Because honestly, I need some reading recommendations. I am so sick of reading my own book. It feels like all I do is read my own book.
我想我们今天的时间就到这里了。非常感谢大家如此投入，一路收听到了节目的尾声。如果你真的听到了这里，我希望你在评论区留下那本曾经改变你人生的书名。哪本书是你最庆幸有人写出来的？哪本书让你觉得它简直就是为你量身定写的？因为说实话，我真的需要一些书单推荐。我真的看够我自己的书了。我感觉我做的一切都只是在读我自己的书。
Like I read it at events and I read it online and I read it out loud and I read it for the audio book and I'm like, I'm sick of you. I don't want to look at you anymore. Just kidding. I love her so much. But I'm ready to read something else in some. I'm ready for a palate cleanser. I'm ready just to feel, you know,
就像我在活动上读它，在网上读它，大声朗读它，为了有声书又读了一遍，然后我心里想：“我看到你都快吐了。我再也不想看到你了。”开玩笑的啦。我超爱这本书的。但我已经准备好阅读点别的了。我准备好洗涤一下大脑了。我准备好去看看别人的大脑里通过他们的文字都在运转着什么奇思妙想了。
I'm ready just to see where it's going on in other people's brains as delivered through their words. So leave a comment below and share this episode with someone who you believe. Might need it, might enjoy it, might love it, might appreciate these tips. Make sure you're following me on Instagram at that psychology podcast to ask future questions for future episodes. Finally, I can't leave without saying this. you have the means, please consider buying a copy of person in progress. It would be greatly appreciated. Until next time, stay safe. Be kind, be gentle with yourself, and we will talk
所以请在下方留言，并将这期节目分享给你认为可能需要它、会喜欢它、会爱上它、会appreciate（欣赏）这些建议的人。确保你在 Instagram 上关注我 @thatpsychologypodcast，以便在未来的节目中提出你们的问题。最后，临走前我必须说：如果你有条件的话，请考虑购买一本《进度条》（Person in Progress）。我们将不胜感激。下次再见前，请注意安全。保持善良，对自己温柔一点，我们
very, very soon. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental
很快就会再聊。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？你们正在收听的是由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯（Keer Games）带来的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间专注于黑人男性的真实经历，进行那些在其他地方根本无法坦诚展开的深入对话，在这里，你将与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人一直在披着一身铠甲。这向全世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。但这并不意味着你需要时刻展现出这种强硬，欢迎在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2%。这就是当旁边有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在当今这个奇特现代世界中培养精神韧性、强健体魄以及构建复原力的科学。
toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed.
经历一些艰难困苦，你终将浴火重生，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。欢迎收听《2%》。名字是数字 2 后面跟 Percent，在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方都可以收听。当一群女性发现她们约会的竟然是同一个劣迹斑斑的骗子时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，
I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app,
我要做他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱惩罚。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。听女朋友的话。相信我，宝贝。在 iHeartRadio App、
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode,
Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back at It》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我和说是一个重大时刻。84年对我意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格里ッシュ。每一集里，
picky here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it, with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. It was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast.
在这里精挑细选，剖析发生的一切，并试着和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起，理清我们是如何度过难关的。就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔在谈论80年代那样。那是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听“Look Back at It”。这是一个IHeart播客。
Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
绝对真人。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。